you're shaking what's wrong with you I'm
nervous
good I'm Annie Onishi Annie is a trauma
surgeon she's explained operating rooms
and surgical procedures in technique
critique as I tell my medical students
vitals are vital we always talk about
them we always want to know what they
are and yes we ask what they are on the
regular and I'm Peter Reuben Peter is a
wired contributor who covers culture and
technology annie is going to teach Peter
how to suture and tie surgical knots
using different materials ranging from
easy to difficult hey Peter you want to
know about surgical knot tying and
suturing technique got time I cross it
off my bucket list
let's get you a distance Grubbs
excellent the first thing we'll learn
today is surgical knot tying how much
does this have in common with tying a
friendship bracelet this is a hundred
percent the same activity as tying a
friendship bracelet oh my god I'm gonna
get the marshmallows let's do this so
typically medical students will learn
this during the first few days of their
surgery rotations and it's an activity
that's mastered over hours and hours of
practice there's actually two types of
knots there's the two-handed knot and
the one-handed knot today I'm going to
be teaching you the one-handed knot
because it's easier turns out it's not
easier it's just more applicable in
general practice this is a knot that we
tight everywhere whether it be we're
fixing the inferior vena cava during a
major trauma case you're sewing little
arteries on the heart or even things as
simple as you're closing skin of a
little laceration in the emergency room
it's all the same knot so Peter to help
you learn that tongue today I brought
you the surgery resident starter pack so
is this like an official training tool
is this what people are gonna start
using in med school this is pretty darn
official when students are first
learning how to tie knots they use
multicolored large-bore yarn just like
this the reason the color is helpful it
will show you that your knot is lying
perfectly as you tie it and a one-handed
tie there's actually two knots there's a
forehand throw and a backhand throw
alright so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
take the white string and hold it in my
left hand so that my purple is crossed
see that okay my forehand throw has an
overhand grip like this like you're
riding the pony okay
can you ride the pony
the pony so with your strings crossed
you're gonna create a four shape do you
see the four do now your index finger is
going to go through the four and loop
this tail and bring it through the four
just like that the whole thing the whole
tail through whole tail through now with
your right hand and your left hand
you're gonna put the knot down and it
should be nice and square
that's excellent Peter good I'm a doctor
you're a doctor
so that's your forehand throw okay now
for your backhand throw left hand comes
back to neutral position with the right
string adjust your grip on the purple
string to a karate chop grip okay now
use your middle finger to get the tail
through the floor what's maintaining
tension on that maintaining tension and
bring it bring it through oh now you
need to cross your hands okay so let's
try it again
okay and then you alternate forehand
back in okay where are you likely to use
this sort of not change so this is a
knot that we tight everywhere whether it
be we're fixing the inferior vena cava
during a major trauma case you're sewing
little arteries on the heart or even
things as simple as you're closing the
skin of a little laceration in the
emergency room it's all the same knot
it's just a matter of what you're tying
what kind of suture so you are doing
this as a chain now depending on the
suture material you're using the most
knots you would ever tie is like eight
or ten okay now here's without fries
here's the difference between menu look
where your purple strands first work
wear my purple string is our you gotta
remove all and and that's gonna give you
a little bit of tension to make this guy
easy but I still got ham hands you're
gonna do it you're these can't be hand
pin check this out oh my god one hand my
god I'm gonna hire it just like the
Nathan not great I look at yours and I
see friendship friendship and here I see
rancor and years of bitterness so I have
a feeling that the answer to this is
going to be everything but what am I
doing wrong
I think the problem is coming as
not is going down you're not applying
even tension so your knots are ending up
stacked instead of square when we teach
the medical students how to do this
they're just doing it constantly they
you can find little strings tied to
everything the the mouse the computer
their pants oh yeah you really don't
have to do much when you cross back over
to the floor hand do yours that you got
it done now what happens when the ends
start getting short then you're done I'm
done right this is good to learn the
mechanics of the knots this is this
doesn't sit like real suture so why
don't we move on to something more
difficult I actually brought some suture
material to show you okay so the way
that suture is labeled is 0 is sort of
the middle set point and something like
a six though is tiny tiny that's that
means six zeros all in a row the easiest
thing to tie is Oh silk and is six over
the finish you can use absolutely not it
goes all the way down to like ten oh but
that's used on very fine things like a
vein or an artery or a nerve so for you
Peter we're gonna use sort of the
elementary school Oh silk this is the
same exact thing as your yarn but what's
gonna make this a little harder is that
your sutures finer so you're gonna have
to work harder to keep good tension and
to make it sit nice so again the
mechanics are the same if it's really
important that you sort of follow the
knot down with your finger to get the
not to sit exactly where you want it to
sit all right Peters let's see so I had
this forehand throw mhr again and use
your oh yes you see how your that was
very instinctive what you did you your
hands sort of crawled up the suture
that's it that's perfect karate chop I
called it now in my brain this is ham
hands because I have ham hands oh you
have beautiful hands you have healing
hands so Peter I actually think you're
ready for the next curve ball oh boy
which is let's get you to do this with
gloves on so there's no like in-between
it's going from the training wheels to
the Grand Prix okay so do doctors
actually do the thing where they're like
yeah let's do this 100% every time let's
do this then okay so let's get started
so Peter this is just gonna be the same
thing same knots but I just want you to
get a sense for how it feels different
when you can actually you know feel the
suture material directly on your
skin it's almost like numbness Wow hey
guess what I'm even more terrible I
didn't think this was possible
hmm that's not the size you like to hear
just interesting many different people
it's the other thing you like to hear
will be didn't that's interesting every
different person makes their own unique
mistake your euphemisms are the best
keep going you're doing great okay
what would you got on there in real life
your hands are wet oh hey um okay so
this is what like the bodily fluid my
choice of my choosing it's actually silk
because it's a braided suture doesn't
make too much of a difference
yes I thought it would be a lot worse if
I give you a monofilament which is like
a plastic one strand that will be harder
with your hands wet but you're doing
really good yay yeah you really I think
mastered the mechanics of the knot tying
you would just need some polishing in
terms of your tension you're not
placement what's gonna be next here what
are we gonna do so I have just the thing
have these creepy skin models with a
bunch of different types of incisions
it's solid and it's kind of a little
giving but it's dense it feels real so I
have for you here a suture kit and a 400
bison on a cutting needle and a cutting
needle is what we use to close skin with
this is an absorbable monofilament okay
for oh so that's a little smaller than
you've been working with so the first
thing you have here is a needle driver
and every surgical instrument locks in
place so practice that mechanism and
then real surgeons don't put their thumb
in that hole push it with the body or
hand and then close it and then you also
need these pickups these are rough
approximations of ads and forceps with
teeth so these have teeth on the end of
it that help you grip skin these aren't
Weezer these are not tweezers these are
called pickups pickups and then that's
the needle now so be careful and you're
gonna oh you put your thumb in the hole
just for that part
hypocrisy good take the whole thing out
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay okay so now the way to properly
hold the needle use your pickups to help
you so I'm gonna hold my needle halfway
back mm-hmm at a 45 degree angle here
and at the very tips of my needle driver
all right so now we're ready to close
skin so what I'm gonna teach you now
it's called the running subcuticular
closure okay
say it with me running subcuticular okay
and this is a nice way to make the skin
come together and there's no stitches
visible okay so I'm gonna pick up the
edge of the knife quote-unquote skin
take one bite sort of right in the apex
of this skin is by it also it is I'm
gonna then what's called protect my
needle so now the sharpen the needle is
protected against this bone okay and I'm
just going to do a couple of one-handed
ties usually three or four for this I'm
alternating and then when you get to the
end I'll show you what to do do you want
to try no but I guess I have to I want
to keep it you expose like me there sure
sure
there we go back to the failure release
your release your needle driver I don't
know
yep exactly push it from behind cuz you
don't usually want to touch the tip of
this you only don't either break air
make it dull so now we're gonna do is
protect your needle that's it perfect
pull through good and now you're ready
to tie do four single-headed throws like
you learned okay okay now the color of
the skin and the color of the filaments
yeah there is not a lot of contrast
going on here can I cheat I'm just gonna
help you none so cuz the point of this
exercise is just so nuts oh yeah you're
getting so good I'm so proud of you I'm
doing good alright so we're gonna
pretend that I did that and now it's
anchored yep so then a running
subcuticular closure if you use your
imagination is good
end up like a series of seas in the
plane of the skin so then your next bite
you're going to avert the opposite side
of the skin you're gonna enter the
tissue sort of exactly opposite to where
you came out and again you're just going
to kind of run along the dimension of
the skin just like so you're gonna use
the back of the needle to push it along
and if you're super slick you'll load
your needle while it's held down there
for you hmm and so the only knots are
really two exactly it's just kind of
ring it together like that so you're
gonna pick up on this side but I did it
that way that's okay so turn your body
so yep that's it so when you're the
operating surgeon you can hip check
people you have to get yourself
comfortable
out my way there's a patient on the
table okay so you're actually gonna come
along this dimension okay again use your
pickups to grow the tissue where you
want it to go and you know in real
subcuticular tissue you want to come out
inside the wound so the petition so that
this stitch gets hidden but that's okay
purposes that's your first bite that's
not the point of this closure is that
you don't see any suture so am I going
across where am I going along no now
you're going across again use your
pickups to show yourself where you want
to go so move along make more progress
which means take a bike with your
pickups closer to your body again and I
come across the tear right but this is
in this dimension so right right and now
with this hand push the tissue there you
go that's perfect great yeah all right
videos over let go pull this out oh no
no but at this rate it's gonna heal
before you yeah yeah yeah even if they
don't look perfect these tend to heal up
okay but you can make this look like
nothing ever happened
which is kind of it which is not what's
happening to your patient oh well
they're gonna have a nice memento of
their time that's right all right so
let's assume that the rest of this is
gonna go flawlessly like that like this
like this so Peter once you get to the
end you're gonna close this with what's
called an Aberdeen hitch okay take the
post again we're protected here
get your right hand through that loop
and you're gonna go grab your post and
bring it through you're not don't don't
let your loop get too small
oh okay okay so I got one good dude all
right yeah keep tension on the post
don't let the loop get too small pull on
that that'll go down well just the
bottom one just this one there you go
just that bottle I'm good and then one
more put that whole thing through yes
nice very good
oh no okay good work too soon okay now
reload your needle all right so now
you're gonna bury this knot so just take
a bite like behind it and come out over
here don't want you virt like that
holding your pickups like that come on
baby oh oh no no oh God
so just pick this at the time at this
point the patient has healed maracas oh
there's a wake as thanking me profusely
I'm ready to be discharged Tom good your
assistant cuts this and then once you're
done with the suture you pass it off to
the scrub protect and you say a needle
back needle back thank you what comics
look how beautiful that is the thing you
did 80% of the point of this is that the
suture is hidden so they don't need to
get them removed and that they just
dissolved all right Peter are you ready
for the next lesson yes please okay
nurse bring in the patient's I've never
seen anything quite like this doctor
most severe case I've seen yet
all right what are we gonna do with this
I think there's already a some sort of
thing going I see a little bruise well I
think first we'll make a little
laceration then we'll close it up
sometimes you have to hurt things to
heal them so true two bananas were
harmed in the making of this video
yeah and is this what how you would make
an actual incision oh no normally an
incision is with a firm hand in a
straight line and just all the way down
yeah
it just depends on what kind of
operation you're doing and then so where
would you see this this is in a skinny
guy like you in little hernia wonderful
yeah well let's just pretend I'm
stitching up my oning
there you go okay so for this particular
model it's best to close a banana
laceration with a simple interrupted
nylon sutures orthopaedic surgeons will
use the ER Doc's will use it but it's
sort of a simpler more straightforward
way to close okay so this is just gonna
pick up on the skin take a nice bite
come right across so how much room
should I leave behind for the night um
you want to poke through because you're
gonna put a couple of these in so and
then which is my post is this my post
yes particular protection needle so the
filament that we're using what kind of
great isn't it so this is a 3o nylon so
nylon is a monofilament non-absorbable
suture and 3oh is slightly larger than
the four oh you were just working with
all right so we got it not yet so then I
would actually trim your tails and you
would put in a separate knot that's the
interrupted Oh
each time as opposed to running so as
you can see I did what you did and then
cut my tails and I started again this is
called an interrupted closure that trim
the tails start over all right what are
you pickups doing right now two hands
what are your pickups done you're gonna
wrap it back careful yeah okay so when
it's really short something that the
orthopods and the ER Doc's do but the
general surgeons don't do which is
called an instrument tie so it's the
same knot but you're just gonna do it
what with your instrument and again
general surgeons don't usually do this
why don't you show me that one because
it's cheesy and it's not nice and it's
not delicate and it's not it looks
similar it is easier but it's not
civilized so I mean you've got the basic
skills down the knot tying the suturing
I think the things that would get built
up to be a little bit more realistic is
a wide open body cavity blood everywhere
everyone's yelling patient's not doing
well you're really nervous you're
exhausted that's probably a little bit
more really this is suboptimal skin
condition indeed yeah your resident may
have to redo your skin closure on this
one bite injury some patients are more
difficult than the others I wouldn't
take it too personally well Annie thank
you for taking the time to show me all
this stuff may it never come in handy
I'm glad that they're people like you to
make sure that it does should always
shake hands with your assistant before
you leave your that is what that is
[Applause]
[Music]